merci Corine CIN de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu nouvellement élu de la scène
Saint- puisque vous avez été élu le 24
septembre dernier et membre du groupe
socialiste on va évidemment revenir sur
l'actualité du Sénat mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est bien sûr ce qui se
passe en en Israël au moins une
française a été tuée dans les attaques
plusieurs autres sont portés disparus on
a vu la amtion claire du Parti
socialiste on va y revenir mais d'abord
Gérald armanin on l'a vu dans le journal
a renforcé la sécurisation des lieux de
la communauté juive est-ce que vous
craignez une importation de ce conflit
dans le pays on sait que c'est déjà
arrivé malheureusement et donc c'est
tout à fait normal c'est la
responsabilité du ministère de
l'Intérieur que de protéger les lieux où
la communauté juive peut seou se
retrouver on sait que malheureusement il
y a du terrorisme islamiste et
antisémite en France on a connu des
attentats on a connu dans le passé les
importations du conflit Isra au
palestinien donc c'est important de
rester vigil ça recommence ouais on va
parler de la réaction de la classe
politique alors dans un communiqué le
Parti socialiste a je cite condamné sans
réserve l'attaque terroriste du Hamas
contre Israël est-ce que vous déplorez
que toute la gauche ne l'ai pas fait
oui mais je crois que ce qui est
important justement c'est quand même de
se concentrer sur ce qui se passe en
Israël au Parti socialiste nous sommes
très clairs nous avons toujours été très
clairs sur ces question sur notre
position concernant la solution à deux
États à laquelle il faut aboutir et euh
y compris d'être capable de condamner
une politique en Israël qui euh euh
aujourd'hui euh ce qui concerne les
coléisations euh n'est pas acceptable
mais en aucun cas on ne peut l'utiliser
pour justifier des attaques terroristes
le terrorisme est toujours inacceptable
le l'organisation Hamas est une
organisation terroriste dont le but
n'est certainement pas de protéger les
poli les populations palestiniennes et
donc euh euh c'est là-dessus que je veux
me me concentrer parce que euh comment
vous qualifiez la réaction de la France
insoumise comment vous avez réagi en
voyant ce communiqu je vais je vais vous
dire très franchement je trouve ça
indigne je trouve ça indigne mais je
crois aussi et et et que et que donc il
va falloir avoir des explications à ce
sujet-l et qu'on en tirera les
conséquences mais je crois que dans le
moment présent consé c'est quoi
c'està-dire vous pouvez plus faire
alliance moi je je pense que la France a
absolument besoin d'une union de la
gauche qui persiste qui perdure qui se
renforce et qui s'étend et ça veut dire
que ça doit se faire sur des bases
claires et c'est dans ce sens là qu'il
va falloir avoir une une explication
claire avec la France
Insou je veux pas rentrer dans ces dans
ces discussions aujourd'hui il y aura
ces discussions elles sont nécessaires
mais
aujourd'hui je crois que l'essentiel
c'est de regarder ce qui se passe depuis
48 he c'est pas la politique
franco-française c'est pas les regarder
le nombrille de la gauche ça c'est
franchement c'est assez minable en
réalité je je crois que ce qui est
important aujourd'hui c'est regarder ça
dit pas quand même quelque chose de la
France insoumise et de ce que porte la
France insoumise oui mais c'est pas
honnêtement aujourd'hui ce que ce qu'il
y a dans la tête de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
et ce que pense la France insoumise
c'est pas le sujet voilà c'est c'est
vraiment on a on a une situation qui est
très inquiétante très préoccupante on a
des informations des images qui nous
arrivent depuis 48 heur qui sont
abominables on a Israël qui subit
probablement la l'attaque terroriste la
plus importante de son histoire on a une
une réponse nécessaire de l'armée
israélienne face à ça qui est très dur
maintenant la la la seule préoccupation
qu'on doit avoir la seule question qu'on
doit se poser c'est comment est-ce que
la communauté internationale peut
intervenir en premier lieu l'Union
européenne et la France doit impulser ça
et les États-Unis pour qu'on a'aille pas
vers une escalade qu'on a'ille pas vers
comme le dit Benjamin you vers une une
guerre longue et qu'on n pas une un
embrasement de tout le le territoire
vous elle est évitable cette guerre
après ce qui s'est passé euh je je m'en
inquiète et c'est pour ça que ça doit
être ça la préoccupation et il faut se
poser la question la seule question
plutôt que les les petites histoires
françaises de de la gauche française la
seule question qu'on doit se poser
aujour c'est vraiment une petite
histoire je je crois est-ce que ça dit
pas quelque chose des valeurs de la
France insoumise et si vous continue à
faire alliance avec eux de la gauche
j'aurais beaucoup de choses à dire sur
ce sujet mais pas aujourd'hui voilà
vraiment vraiment moi je je ne veux pas
me laisser entraîner je vous je vous dis
très je ve pas s'entraîner aujourd'hui
dans ce débat là parce que aujourd'hui
la seule question qui m'intéresse c'est
pourquoi le Hamas a choisi de perpétrer
des des attentats aussi graves aussi
sanglants dans ce moment en Israël en
sachant très bien la la réaction que ça
provoquerait et donc le risque
d'embraisement pour toute la région mais
vous le dites vous-même il y a un risque
d'importation du conflit il y a une
inquiétude bien évidemment dans la
communauté juive est-ce que là il y a
pas une forme d'antisémitisme du parti
une partie de la France insoumise il y a
un antisémitisme en France qui
malheureusement persiste depuis très
longtemps et il y a parfois euh et à
gauche et à droite des prises
d'opposition qui sont problématiques
voilà et donc je pense qu'effectivement
ça doit ça devra faire aussi partie des
discussions qu'on doit avoir et du débat
qu'on doit avoir et le Parti socialiste
qui a toujours été irréprochable sur ces
questionsl aura sa responsabilité pour
poser des positions claires et pour
appeler toute la gauche à nous rejoindre
sur ces positions là ça pose la question
de la nuup comme le dit Jérôme GCH quand
même je vous l'ai dit c'est une question
qui se posera
on va parler des sénatoriales et de ce
qui va arriver maintenant au Sénat
puisqueaprès la période d'élection
sénatoriale le Sénat reprend ses travaux
cette semaine on va voir quels sont les
textes au menu avec notre journaliste
Alex
[Musique]
pousard bonjour Alex bonjour ran bonjour
Corine Narassiguin bonjour et Alex les
sénateurs vont commencer cette semaine
par l'examen d'une proposition de loi
pour mieux protéger les élus locaux oui
c'est un texte porté par la majorité de
droite et du centre du Sénat qui fait
suite aux violences qu'on subit certains
élus locaux cette année on se souvient
par exemple pendant les émeut de cet été
du maire de Laï rose dans le Val de
Marne dont la voiture avait été
incendiée devant son domicile on se
souvient également du maire de
Saint-Brévin lespins en Loire Atlantique
qui a démissionné après avoir subi les
pressions de l'extrême droite et après
l'incendie de son domicile ce texte
sénatorial propose notamment d'aligner
les peines encourues en cas de violence
sur un élu local sur les peines
encourues en cas de violence sur sur les
forces de l'ordre la semaine prochaine
les premiers projets de loi de la
session parlementaire seront portés par
le gouvernement au Sénat il s'agit
notamment du projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques un
texte qui vise notamment à respecter nos
objectifs européens en matière de
déficit faute de majorité il y a 2
semaines à l'Assemblée nationale le
gouvernement était passé par le 493 pour
faire adopter ce texte et puis il y a
aussi le projet de loi sur le partage de
la valeur qui va être débatue entre les
sénateurs c'est un texte qui a fait
l'objet d'un accord entre les partenair
sociaux entre syndicat et patronat pour
mieux répartir la richesse produite dans
une entreprise et puis enfin on peut
citer le projet de loi sur les
négociation commerciale dans la grande
distribution qui doit fournir des outils
pour stopper la spirale de la hausse des
prix alors Alex vous nous parler de
cette proposition de la majorité
sénatoriale sur les élus locaux mais les
sénateurs LR ont d'autres propositions
de loi notamment celle pour interdire
l'écriture inclusive oui le point médian
ou l'écriture inclusive d'une manière
générale ce n'est pas la tasse de thé de
la droite sénatoriale qui dépose cette
proposition de loi pour interdire
l'usage de l'écriture inclusive
notamment dans les administrations à
gauche les sénateurs communistes vont
eux faire une proposition de loi pour
instaurer une amnistie vis-à-vis des
délits qui sont commis lors des
mouvements sociaux le débat sur ces deux
textes promet d'être agité dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat et puis ce sera le
gros morceau de cette session
parlementaire en tout cas de ce début de
session parlementaire le projet de loi
immigration porté par le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald de Darmanin il doit
être examiné au Sénat à partir du 6
novembre alors on sait déjà que la
droite droite sénatoriale est
farouchement opposé à la régularisation
des travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers en tension une mesure prévue par
le texte du Gouvernement qui d'ailleurs
est soutenu par les sénateurs centristes
qui forment avec les républicains cette
majorité au Sénat donc le débat
s'annonce très intéressant sur ce point
et puis enfin en novembre on entrera
dans le vif du marathon budgétaire au
Sénat avec le début de l'examen du
budget de la Sécurité sociale pour 2024
ce sera le 13 novembre et 10 jours plus
tard les sénateurs commenceront à
débattre du budget de l'État pour l'an
prochain le gouvernement prévoyant 16
milliards d'euros d'économie mais ce
n'est ce n'est pas suffisant pour la
droite sénatoriale Corine narassigin on
va commencer par parler du plus gros
morceau de cette session parlementaire
au Sénat du projet de loi immigration
est-ce que ce texte avec d'un côté un
volet social sur la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier et de l'autre
un volet de fermeté euh sur euh et bien
des mesures qui vont faciliter
l'expulsion notamment des étrangers
délinquants est-ce que vous pourriez le
voter dans l'état non bien sûr que non
et je je crois que globalement je ne
vois pas très bien quelles améliorations
le gouvernement pourrait apporter qui
nous permettrait vraiment de de voter ce
texte il y a effectivement un article
qui nous paraît aller dans le bon sens
qui concerne la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers intention et et chez les
socialistes que ce soit chez les
Sénateurs les députés et globalement au
Parti socialiste nous pensons que ça ne
va pas même assez loin qu'il faut avoir
une véritable politique économique de
l'immigration qui soit beaucoup plus
inclusive beaucoup plus ouverte et qui
prennent en compte la régularisation de
tous les travailleurs sans papier et pas
uniquement dans les métiers en tension
je pense que c'est plutôt ça que nous
nous souhaiterons nous souhaitons mettre
sur la table mais déjà c'est un pas dans
la bonne direction mais c'est à peu près
tout ce qu'il y a de positif dans CF
sauf que vous le voterez pas alors que
c'est une mesure qui est faite pour la
gauche c'est titre de séjour pour les
travailleurs sans écoutz ça n'est pas
parce queil y a on pourrait voter
l'article si l'article au final nous
convient mais on peut pas ça ne peut pas
suffire à voter une loi globalement qui
qui est un recul qui a un recul parce
qu'on voit bien qu'on va ajouter du
chaos au chos avec des mesures encore
plus répressive et donc on va avoir de
plus en plus de de décisions de qtf qui
sont inapplicables des gens qui sont qui
seront pas expulsables en réalité on a
le recul sur la me je pense qu'on
va une remise en cause du droit du sol
dans ce texte qui est inadmissible quand
on est républicain et donc tout ça c'est
pas possible quel est l'intérêt pour le
gouvernement de discuter avec vous et de
chercher des compromis avec vous si de
toute façon vous ne votez pas le texte
on verra ce qui se passe à l'Assemblée
nationale je crois que peut-être il y a
il y a des il y a des sujets un peu
différents dans les rapports de force à
l'Assemblée nationale et au et au Sénat
mais est-ce que là vous n'êtes pas en
train de pousser le gouvernement à
regarder sur sa moi moi je ne crois pas
de toute façon que le gouvernement a
jamais regardé sur sa gauche d'ailleurs
on on a bien parler la loi de
programmation de finances qui est encore
passé au
493 voilà donc elle ne regarde jamais
sur sa gauche en réalité c'est la gauche
qui a chois choisi de
faire de souligner le fait qu'il y avait
un élément positif dans ce projet de loi
et de manifester notre soutien à cet
article là mais sa que là y a une forme
en même temps dans ce projet de loi il y
avait une jambe droite une jambe gauche
on a la droite d'un côté qui met des
conditions mais qui se dit prête à voter
le texte et vous vous dites bon de toute
façon on votera pas ça va forcément
pousser le gouvernement à seourner ver
gouverement le gouvernement se tourne
déjà vers les LR de toute façon quand le
projet de loi a été
débattu au Sénat en commission des lois
au mois de mars
c'était avec la droite que le
gouvernement discutait c'était pas avec
la gauche sur laame justement Gérald
armanin ce weekend dans Le Parisien a
dit pour le coup se ranger à la position
des républicains à titre personnel et il
veut transformer les républicains qui
veulent transformer la me en Amu en aide
médicale d'urgence qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez c'est une erreur c'est une erreur
et c'est euh c'est très démagogique euh
et très contreproductif ça n'a aucune
efficacité financière la me c'est c'est
Z0 ,4 % du budget de l'Assurance Maladie
aujourd'hui donc c'est pas vraiment un
poids sur les finances publiques et puis
surtout euh ça veut dire ça veut dire en
fait surcharger les urgences ça veut
dire ça veut dire en fait créer de
nouvelles dépenses qui seront plus
difficiles à contrôler qui pourrait être
plus lourd pour la collectivité et puis
c'est aussi on a eu le covid quand même
ne pas considérer
que pouvoir se donner les moyens de
prévenir euh des nouvelles épidémies euh
avec des populations qui sont
extrêmement exposé à des risques
épidémiologiques chroniques c'est une
faute c'est un c'est un
problème
trans ça veut dire que ça veut dire déjà
c'est c'est l'aide médicale durence
c'est déjà sousutilisé en réalité elle
le droit n'est pas exercé à plein ce qui
veut bien dire qu'en réalité la plupart
des migrants qui viennent ici il
viennent pas pour notre couverture
sociale ils sont même pas au courant de
qu'elle existe en fait donc c'est il y a
pas des histoires d'appel d'air ça c'est
idiot et et donc on voit bien là par par
contre on se prive d'outils de
prévention sanitaire et de et de et de
régulation sanitaire dans le pays et
puis c'est une question d'humanisme tout
simplement alors ça c'est la position
personnelle he de Gérald armanin il le
dit he de soutenir les al Elisabeth
borne elle a dit qu'elle va confier une
mission àatrick stéphanini et à Claude
devvin qui est socialiste et que des
conclusions de cette mission découlera
la position du gouvernement c'est la
bonne méthode écoutez moi je vais pas
commenter sur la Bro qui existe au sein
du du gouvernement de d'Élisabeth borne
on va bien que là il y a un problème
avec avec un ministre de l'Intérieur qui
prend des initiatives soitdisant
personnell alors qu'on on va justement
bientôt reprendre l'examen de de ce
texte au Sénat que il si patri Stéphan
et claud devvin valide la transformation
en Amu qu'est-ce que vous ferez ben nous
on veêta contre même si ça vient deux
bien sûr Alex il y a d'autres textes on
en a parlé ah oui le premier texte de la
session parlementaire au Sénat c'est
cette semaine et il concerne les élus
locaux il vise à mieux les protéger des
des violences est-ce que selon vous il
faut aligner les peines de prison pour
les auteurs de violence contre les élus
locaux sur les peines de prison en cas
de violence contre les forces de l'ordre
est-ce que vous êtes favorable à cette
mesure euh dans l'ensemble le texte et
et va plutôt dans la bonne direction en
réalité ça ce type de mesure en fait le
fait qu'il faut vraiment à la fois
symboliquement et dans les faits
renforcer la protection des élus locaux
on voit bien qu'il y a il y a des il y a
une recrudesence des violences qui sont
subies par les élus c'est important et
ce sont la
le cœur de ce de ce de cette proposition
de loi en fait reprend des propositions
que nous avions faites avec les
socialistes dans une notre proposition
de loi qui avait été déposée par
ericouche et Didier Marie avant l'été et
donc dans ce sens-là nous sommes
globalement d'accord par contre il y a
il y a quelques il y a quelques articles
que nous estimons être un peu
démagogiques ou inutiles mais mais qui
sont euh il y a il y a des il y a des
propositions par exemple sur la
protection des système tique la donner
droit à la protection à tous les
candidats et donc là là je pense que on
pense que ça va trop loin voilà et que
il faut pas non plus donner l'impression
que être candidat ou être élu c'est une
caste à part et que et que toute
confrontation tout débat un peu vif sur
les marchés deviendrait une agression
voilà donc faut quand même pas aller
trop loin non plus dans dans ce qu'on
propose par contre je pense que
globalement cette cette proposition de
loi on la voit d'un bon œil alors vos
collègues communistes vont également
faire ition pour instaurer une amnistie
concernant certains délits qui sont
commis lors des mouvements sociaux
est-ce que les socialistes sont pour
alors c'est un sujet c'est un débat
qu'on a on a de manière récurrente avec
avec au sein de avec N nos partenaires à
gauche je pense que c'est
euh on peut on on on peut s'inquiéter on
va dire
de d'une forme de criminalisation du
droit de grève qui existe
chez le chez Géral amamin en particulier
mais dans ce gouvernement depuis
quelques années et que donc qu'on qu'on
s'en inquiète est une bonne chose
maintenant criminalisation du droit de
grève mais je pense qu'il y a quand même
une une volonté depuis un moment de la
part de Hal il y a quand même beaucoup
de de manifestations qui sont interdites
de manière abusive il y a quand même une
une
politique de de maintien de l'ordre qui
vise à créer le chaos et à créer le
conflit dans c'est pas des questions de
trouble à l'ordre publique pour vous
c'est une remise en Cuse du droit de rve
moi je pense que par contre c'est là où
je pense que voilà il y a un ma c'est
que il faut faire attention à à ne pas
non
plus donner l'impression que quand on va
dans les manifestations c'est normal
d'aller casser c'est normal de créer de
créer de violenter d'attaquer la police
de de de détruire des biens publics ou
des biens privés ça évidemment ça n'est
pas acceptable et
donc c'est le c'est pour ça qu'il y a un
débat à gauche sur cette question là et
donc les socialistes nous sommes autant
nous sommes très attachés à défendre le
le droit de grève le droit de manifester
autant il ne faut pas donner
l'impression que nous avons une
tolérance vis-à-vis de la violence dans
les manifestations donc l'amistice c'est
oui ou c'est non pour les socialistes on
va voir le honnêtement je vais pas
parler moi aujourd'hui au nom du du
groupe auoc parce que c'est une
discussion qu'on n pas encore eu en
groupe et donc je pe pas me permettre
mais mais mais je mais je crois que mais
au Parti socialiste en général
l'amnistie globale ça n'est pas quelque
chose que auquel nous sommes favorables
vous venez d'être élu sénatrice on l'a
dit Corine narassigin comment vous
appréendez ce nouveau
mandat
avec avec beaucoup de fierté et puis
avec vraiment la la le sens de la
responsabilité de il y a beaucoup de
travail devant moi et qu'il y a une il y
a des exigences pour être à la hauteur
des enjeux qui
sont du travail parlementaire dans cette
dans cette belle maison qui est le Sénat
et et aussi des attentes euh par rapport
à un département que je représente
aujourd'hui qui est la scè saint et où
il y a beaucoup d'enjeux qui sont très
spécifiques à la sain S mais qui aussi
sont très représentatifs je crois des
enjeux de tout le pays qu'est-ce que
vous voulez porter comme dossier alors
je vais déjà être particulièrement
impliqué dans le projet de loi sur
l'immigration depuis la commission des
lois mais plus généralement moi mon
engagement politique depuis des années
ça a toujours été toutes les questions
de lutte contre les inégalités contre
les discriminations qui tous ces sujets
qui font le ciment de la la cohésion
weekend et donc ça va continuer à être
le le sujet majeur de de mon travail
j'ai aussi un biais parce que je suis
ingénieure en télécommunication sur tout
ce qui impacte des des nouvelles
technologies sur la société je m'y
intéresseraiis aussi mais je veux
m'interdire aucun sujet a priori je
pense que c'est important que on on
reste pas dans des silos avec les
écologistes qui font de l'écologie les
socialistes qui font de la culture et
voilà donc c'est c'est c'est c'est
important de pouvoir travailler sur tout
et de pas avoir de pas avoir de tabou
merci Alex à tout à l'heure touthe on
continuera à parler du projet de loi
immigration ce sera à suivre dans le
club voir l'actualité dans nos régions
avec nos partenaire de la presse
régionale on va à Bordeaux retrouver
Jefferson des sport bonjour Jefferson
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous grand
reporter à sud ouest on va reparler
politique puisque c'est à Bordeaux que
le parti présidentiel s'est donné
rendez-vous ce weekend comp plus de
rentrer de renaissance et cap sur les
européennes pour le parti présidentiel
Jefferson exactement bonjour in oui à
Bordeaux alors bien entendu les
l'attaque du Hamas contre Israël a
dominé les débats mais au-delà les
macronistes ont mis le cap sur les
Européennes de 2023 Renaissance horizon
et le modem partiront Unis Corine
narassigin ce n'est pas le cas au sein
des alliés de l'anupes ce sera chacun
pour soi est-ce que la gauche pour ces
européennes a enclenché la machine à
perdre la lueur des divisions qui
s'annoncent les élections européennes
sont une élection proportionnell euh sur
laquelle il est habituel qu'on parte
séparer et il y a d'autres d'autres pays
européens là tous les autres pays
européens en réalité à gauche y compris
quand des partis sont ensemble au
gouvernement en coalition ils
choisissent de partir séparés sur les
élections
européennes et donc c'est aussi je crois
le l'objectif qu'on doit avoir dans ces
élections c'est le maximum d'élus
européens de la gauche et de l'écologie
et on peut on peut peut-être même avoir
plus d'élus en partant séparément qu'en
partant tous ensemble prère fois
c'est'est passé ricraac pour le PS
est-ce que vous êtes inquiète là de
passer la barre des 5 % qui donnent des
députés ou non bien sûr on a toujours
cette inquiétude je crois qu'aujourd'hui
le Parti socialiste n'est plus dans le
même état que en en 2019 mais bien sûr
c'est notre notre objectif c'est
évidemment de porter haut le projet
européen que les militants viennent de
voter et que nous allons présenter en
convention nationale ce samedi 14
octobre et et et et de
convaincre un maximum de Françaises et
de français de de le porter avec nous
dans cette élection reste à savoir qui
va le porter est-ce que ce sera un
socialiste ou est-ce que vous repartez
avec place publique et Raphael glxman ça
ce sont des débats qu'on aura en interne
dans les prochaines semaines moi je
crois que c'est d'abord ce qu'on a dit
c'est c'est ce qu'on a dit au Parti
socialiste c'est que tous ceux qui
veulent porter avec nous ce projet sont
les bienvenus et et et donc on va voir
donc vous êtes prêt à nouveau à laisser
la tête de liste à une personne qui
n'est pas encarté au parti pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas bien sûr il y a il y a euh
la famille socialiste doit être
représentée dans dans dans cette
élection de manière la plus ouverte et
la plus large possible mais toujours
aussi dans un esprit de respect de nos
partenaires à gauche parce que même si
on part sur des listes séparées euh
notre attention à la direction du Parti
socialiste ça sera toujours euh de ne
pas euh justement raviver une bataille
euh à gauche euh parce que nos
adversaires euh dans euh dans cette
élection euh ce sera bien sûr la
politique libérale qui est incarnée par
la droite et en particulier celle de
celle d'Emmanuel Macron et puis bien sûr
nos ennemis dans cette dans cette
élection ça reste l'extrême droite et et
les le populisme anti-européen de
l'extrême drest une dernière question
Jefferson oui oui oui Corine narassigen
je reste sur les européennes regardons
un petit peu plus loin comment expliquer
finalement ce chacun pour soi et le
justifier en se disant qu'on peut
peut-être gagner plus de postes et
promettre à la fois un candidat commun
de la gauche à la présidentielle de 2027
est-ce qu'il n'y avait pas là l'occasion
en tout cas l'occasion de faire une
démonstration que l'Union à gauche était
possible comme ça avait été le cas au
législative on sent que cette alliance
de anupes est plus fragile que jamais
nous avions proposé au Parti socialiste
une méthode qui était de de confronter
nos projets euh pour euh conforter tous
les combats communs et qui sont nombreux
que nous portons ensemble et que nous
continuerons à porter ensemble au
Parlement européen euh et mais aussi de
se parler très honnête des divergences
parce qu'il y en a et il faut pas les
cacher euh malheureusement cette ce
débat là n'a pas eu lieu il y a eu des
décisions qui ont été prises par
d'autres parties que le Parti socialiste
de de de partir seul très tôt mais comme
je vous l'ai dit je pense que ce sont
des des des élections qui ont des
logiques
différentes et que au lendemain des
européennes et que déjà pendant la
campagne des européenne il faudra comme
je l'ai dit prendre regarde à ne pas se
tromper d'adversaire et puis au lemain
des européennes reprendre pleinement le
fil de la construction de cette union
parce que sinon on va encore avoir la
droite et l'extrême droite au deuxième
tour en 2027 avec une véritable chance
de voir l'extrême droite gagner et ça ça
n'est pas acceptable merci Jefferson
merci d'avoir été avec nous c'est Israël
à la Une de Sud-Ouest ce matin comme
dans beaucoup de titres de la presse
régionale la guerre sera longue et
difficile c'est le titre de votre
journal merci beaucoup Jefferson d'avoir
été avec nous merci Corine narassiginci
d'avoir été notre invité pendant cette
première demi-heure